now some of them have said this is a
bridge too far right for our democracy
and we respect differences of opinion
that's our democracy we welcome the fry
the conversation the debate that it's
not a question of I don't like what you
believe so therefore uh you're not right
no that's your right you represent your
district and that's it but if you're not
honoring the oath of office if you don't
respect our democracy that is a that is
a a line that cannot be crossed how many
times did she say democracy man what
would you like for lunch I think I would
democracy have the Double Quarter
democracy Pounder with democracy cheese
and maybe man would you like a medium or
a large I'd like a democracy uh large I
want a large democ ice diet democracy
diet democracy democracy Coke democracy